for 15 year old giatti the day begins at
six in the morning
she works on the streets of delhi in her
neighborhood to the east of the city
center
it's loud here and dangerous
giotti collects plastic bottles
newspapers and cardboard what others
throw away she turns into
we money to collect trash for our family
to survive my father is ill my mother
doesn't earn anything either so my
brother and i work to feed our family
she usually works three or four hours in
the mornings
days she doesn't find enough stuff to
recycle
the material struggle is compounded by
an emotional one
people don't treat us with respect
sometimes men across the girls and shout
abuse sometimes people hit us because
they think we are stealing we're just
collecting bottles then we end up at the
police station and get abused there too
one kilogram of plastic bottles is worth
40 rupees or about half a euro
it's money giotti's family desperately
needs
they live together under a bridge on a
busy road surrounded by traffic noise
day and night
it's illegal to live here
they could be driven out any day
jonty is the first member of her family
who's trying to leave this life behind
we're nomads we have no security we're
always at the mercy of the police
it's a good thing jyoti is taking a
different path
police
after work grt goes to school
the children learn reading writing and
math but also life skills
brushing their teeth every day is part
of the program
the school is one of about a hundred in
delhi run by the ngo chetna at its
learning centers for street and working
children
chetna stands for childhood enhancement
through training and action
jyoti is also involved with barak nama
children's stories
delhi's only paper written by and for
street kids
the contributors and editors are
discussing the last edition and planning
the next one
the lead story is going to be about a
telephone hotline for children in danger
the paper was set up 10 years ago it was
children who came up with the idea
they wanted to tell their stories
the opportunity to take charge to make
our own decisions
we're independent here
nobody tells us what to put on the front
page or on the other pages
jyoti wants to see a story about
children who have managed to break their
drug habit
drugs among street kids is a serious
problem
when children see their photo in the
paper they suddenly realize that they
are somebody that's how i felt when i
first saw my picture in balagnama i
really felt good and after that i
decided to go more often to the learning
center
jyoti wants to inspire others to seize
the initiative and work for a better
life
she's visiting taimur nagar a slum of
trash collectors
she wants to impress on these kids how
important it is to get an education
they've written poems and jyoti will
have them published in balochnama
she can imagine working as a journalist
when she's grown up
i want to give people a voice
street kids do all kinds of incredible
things
and despite all their problems they want
to give their lives meaning
and i want to write about that
for children in taiwan
giatti is already something of a hero a
role model
there is no easy way to escape poverty
but giotti has the determination to try
and someday
leave behind the world of collecting
rubbish to make a living